my name is james hall i'm a pumpkin
carver i've won halloween wars twice and
a number of online contests today i've
been challenged to explain pumpkin
carving in 13 levels of increasing
complexity
[Music]
[Applause]
pumpkin carving is kind of a realm where
a lot of skill is required there's a lot
of crash that you have to learn the
further you get into it and you're on
the clock because as soon as you cut
into that pumpkin it's starting to rot
so you learn to let go of the things
that you worked hard at what we're going
to be creating here today are just the
designs that i brought no design is
really better or worse than another this
is my interpretation of the challenge
level one basic jack-o-lantern it's just
the two triangle eyes simple mouth maybe
your nose if you're feeling really
really fancy i'm choosing this pumpkin
because it's just got that classic shape
when you see illustrations of
jack-o'-lanterns on little posters or
halloween cards they all look like this
first i'm going to go ahead and cut the
top off so i can get to all the guts
inside do not cut straight down you want
to go and add an angle to cut that lid
because if you go straight up and down
you'll put the pumpkin lid on there and
it'll just drop all the way through this
is just like the little basic plastic
pumpkin scoop you get the pumpkin
carving kits if you don't have one of
these a spoon will work
then you just start off by drawing what
you want to carve into the pumpkin any
kind of washable felt-tip marker will
work if you don't like it you take a
white paper towel and start over again
then you will go ahead and cut the
facial details out and you're going to
be cutting all the way through the
pumpkin wall i prefer fillet knives
because if you use a knife that's a bit
too hefty when you're cutting it'll grip
and then when you pull it also it'll pop
free which is a good way to accidentally
cut pieces off the pumpkin and your
finger easy mistakes to make placement
of the facial features take a step back
otherwise you end up carving an eye and
realizing that your second eye is an
inch lower and twice as big which isn't
necessarily a bad thing pumpkins are
supposed to be monstrous and ugly anyway
you can
do the classic artist thing and lie and
so you did something on purpose because
you're a genius this is the classic
jack-o'-lantern cut the top off make
sure you go at an angle scoop it out
really good then you just cut the two
eyes the nose and the mouth and that's
it level two embellished jack-o-lantern
the important thing to remember when
you're adding embellished details paying
attention to what a face actually does
not just plain triangle for an eye but
adding maybe some creases in the corner
to show one eye is squinting varying the
size to chill one eye is more open so
what i'll do first is go ahead and raise
the corner of the mouth up follow the
line you already established you can
even come back carve in the corners that
way you get that crease that you get at
the corner of your mouth when you smile
really big next i want to give this eye
a little bit of a crease here to make it
look like it's squinting slightly from
the
smile
actually bringing the eye outward a
little give it a little bit of a curve
next to make this eye look like it's
actually shut a little bit more than
this one this eye has to be expanded
another thing you can do is modify the
nose just a tiny bit because as with
everything else when your face does
something big like smile your nose will
change just a tiny bit just a bit of a
sneer don't forget if you're carving a
pumpkin there's more than one side if
you mess that up turn it around start
again turn that side to the wall when
you light it a really good way to play
with any jack lantern is just add more
teeth i find that's a good answer for
pretty much any monster design and there
you have very slightly embellished
jack-o-lantern the same thing as the
first just with a tiny bit more
character for level three what we're
doing is actually trying to make a
representation of an image on the
pumpkin level three realistic pumpkin
instead of just carving a triangle and
saying that's an eye you're going to be
carving the shapes that light makes when
it bounces off an object it's kind of
like the difference between having a
piece of paper and drawing a smiley face
on it and then having a piece of paper
and printing out a photograph on it
start by drawing the image on the
pumpkin
even for people that have been doing
this a long time that is always a good
step this design is going to be kind of
a classic european dragon they're good
for halloween because they're the angry
version of a dragon one of the other
things you have to draw up with the
marker first is highlights pick a source
if you have a face and the light is
supposed to be coming from the right
side you're going to be carving out like
a spot here and a spot here even if it's
something imaginary light still bounces
off pretty much the same way
then cut the top off since this pumpkin
is bigger it's going to be a lot thicker
this is a drywall saw you can get it at
any hardware store this thing goes
through pumpkin incredibly well so it'll
take the top off very easily
once again just get everything out of
there you're going to have to be a
little bit more persistent with it you
want to try to get the pumpkin wall nice
and smoothed out and even next thing
we're going to do is start carving some
of the highlights out of this pumpkin if
you've drawn on here with a marker
there's a good chance that while you're
working on it
it'll automatically erase a lot of the
marker lines pumpkin juice is really
good at taking ink off what i'm doing
now is going in and putting in a little
bit of an outline you want to make sure
that you don't carve an outline in an
unbroken line all the way around the
piece because then there's nothing but
this tiny bit here supporting all this
pumpkin hanging out there you really
have to make sure that you build in
little support systems in here the tip
of the horn doesn't necessarily have to
be showing it's implied you know it's
there same thing with the tongue that's
the whole reason that tongue is there in
the first place otherwise the pumpkin is
almost certainly gonna break on you
now this is at an early stage it's
almost an abstraction of dragon the more
detail you add to it the more pronounced
it's gonna get so the next steps you're
gonna start to see this thing take shape
a lot more level four adding a
background this level is much more
complex because by adding a background
you're telling more of a story and it
takes a lot more thoughts and possibly a
few more tricks like perspective and you
want to make sure that when you draw
your background you account for the
connection spots you want to make sure
those lines connect into that so you
still maintain that kind of support then
you just go ahead and cut out whatever
it is you've decided on at this point
you really want to be using like a fine
saw if you're trying to get this kind of
detail the main thing is take your time
remember the more you cut away
the more flimsy the pumpkin becomes this
thing is round so it's an organic shape
it'll display organic shapes more easily
for the dragon i'm going to put them in
a cave a hallway or a room that involves
carving straight lines problem is if you
try to carve a straight line across the
pumpkin from certain angles it will
always look like it's bent with an
organic background you got a little more
room to play with you can view it from
over here over here and it still looks
essentially the same now you can see
with level four by adding a background
it really makes the detail pop on this
because you've got contrast of the dark
shape here with the bright background
and some of the later levels we can go
in and add a little bit of detail and a
little bit of definition because right
now this is still a very simplified
version of this scene for the next level
let's increase the detail level five
layered carving
you want to get the most out of whatever
image that you've chosen and to do that
you really need to work with more than
just black and white the outer rind of a
pumpkin is opaque that's what blocks a
light if you shave off just that dark
layer of skin the pumpkin meat
underneath is actually translucent you
put a light behind it it'll still show
through you'll have a nice range of
shades you can go through the deeper you
carve the brighter it gets i'm going to
start off by
working on the dragon itself i want to
make sure that i get all the highlights
right where i want them to be and any
place where there's going to be a really
dark section you can just leave the rind
on that surface whereas with a regular
sculpture will you carve in that's where
the shadow is going to be it's reverse
you're essentially carving in negative
you now have to find the right tool and
just shave off different layers of the
pumpkin these are ones that i've made
myself and it's just
a bristle from a street sweeper that
came off oddly enough these things are
made of really really good high carbon
steel so they actually sharpen up and
last better than the store-bought ones
and then just a stick i think this used
to be part of a christmas tree obviously
this one will cut out a round shape
whereas this one will give you a nice
sharp line you can't just go to the art
store and buy a little pack of loop
tools you probably are gonna have to
sharpen them up first because you need
something with a good edge to go through
pumpkin it's very fibrous and it'll like
to rip apart and fray now i finished
with this level so i've added a little
bit more detail to the face added scales
highlighted the teeth and gave the
background a little bit more definition
but i'm sure we can get a bit more
detail in this so let's move on to the
next level level six back carving we're
adding complexity to this by carving on
the inside a tricky technique because
you're carving without being able to see
exactly what you're doing so you're
essentially working blind i'm going to
be using this technique on the dragon to
highlight the top of the neck because
it's going to be covered in scale detail
and once that's in there it's a lot
easier to go in and do large go
highlight from the back than it is to
try to go in and carve out each
individual little scale that i think
needs to be brighter the details i'm
trying to highlight are the areas where
the light would be strongest eye sockets
and cheekbones and jaw lines those are
things that we look at and it helps us
read a face just a little bit faster for
this level you want to leave the light
on especially if you don't have any
areas that are cut out and it's just
solids with a bit of the rind shaved off
you really want to have that light on
because then your best guess is going to
be based on the shadow that you see
through the surface you're working on a
surface that's curved around your hand
it's a concave surface with a chisel or
a gouge those tools will go forward and
then dig out and if the piece is bending
away from it that works really well if
it's bending into it it's a lot harder
to get that to curve so loop tools are a
better way to go and now that we're done
you can see kind of the highlights along
the scales any place where the light is
supposed to hit it and a little bit
along the mouth to define it a bit along
the horn of the cheekbones
if you're doing a detailed piece the
easiest way to go ahead and hack off a
lot and give you really strong
highlights and broad areas is to go
through the back and carve it out after
you've fleshed out the details if you've
done it right you should end up with a
pumpkin that you're pretty happy with if
not you end up with something that you
can throw in your neighbor's yard next
we're gonna move into a new pumpkin to
show you some more complex levels of
pumpkin carving level seven three
dimensional carving 3d carving is
carving the pumpkin like you're
sculpting a piece of stone or carving a
piece of wood you really have to know
the object in three dimensions if you're
carving a face
you need to know about how far the nose
comes out from the face how deep the
eyes sink in shadow's going to form just
due to the way that light falls on this
actual object now it can be very much
equal to or for some people easier to do
but this is going to draw on skills that
most people have never used when carving
a pumpkin first you want to make sure
you get the rind off so you have a nice
blank canvas to work with i'm choosing
to carve a monster into this pumpkin
pretty much because of the shape of this
pumpkin because this has this nice knob
here that very easily becomes a head
places where it's flat
are where the pumpkin is at its thinnest
flat parts lends itself well to lit
carving curvier it is the more it lends
itself to sculpting the next step is
sketch out a basic design not with a
marker but with the end of a loop tool
since you're going to be carving all
these details back further any lines
that you make here are going to
disappear anyway i'm carving and taking
meat out here to create a shadow
underneath something whereas with
carving i'm carving that meat out to
create a highlight as you're carving
into the pumpkin you want to feel
everyone smile how soft the pumpkin is
once you really start to get through the
pumpkin wall it'll give a little bit
more and you'll be able to feel the
fibers of the pumpkin and you know that
you don't want to carve any deeper into
that area this is a foam rasp you can
find that in any hardware store this
will take off small layers at a time
the curve under the cheekbone that goes
down into the jaw line this is an
excellent tool to get that nice subtle
curve because sometimes you put a loop
tool in there and drag it and it's going
to take off a bit more than you want now
this little tool is good for getting
very fine detail and as the sculpture
goes on you're going to progress from
larger tools down to smaller ones you
want ones that pop some of the extra
little pieces out and if you remember
with the embellish jack-o-lantern i
turned the corner up to give it more of
a sneer and you could tell that's what's
going on here the same ideas of
observation and memorizing exactly what
the corners of the mouth do
that being said
this is a totally different process you
have to use loop tools to kind of carve
out where the eyes are and recess them
and sculpt them out exactly how you want
them to look going into the next level
we're going to be using the whole form
of this pumpkin to kind of describe this
scene as opposed to the previous
pumpkins where we just been using a
single side level eight sculpting a
background adding a background is going
to be very different than the background
we added in the previous levels you're
cutting
into the pumpkin as much as you can to
push the background back but not so deep
that you're cutting all the way through
the pumpkin the tools we're going to be
using are going to be the same as the
previous step now what i'm doing this is
kind of
letting the pumpkin dictate what exactly
should be carved by that i mean i'm just
kind of paying attention to the natural
shape of it because of this bulge here
and the way it sticks out it
automatically makes me think of a
shoulder you have to take the whole
thing
into account pretty much at all times
the very least until you get everything
basically roughed out you really can't
focus in on one small spot what i'm
doing right now is trying to separate
the head from the background of the
pumpkin and by doing that also help
define the shoulder a little bit that
foam rest is going to become very
important because one of the easiest
ways to uniformly push back that pumpkin
wall so the subject stands forward is to
take that rasp and just keep shaving
down and shaving down and do it a little
bit at a time it can be a bit tedious
but it's better to do that than to
accidentally punch all the way through
the pumpkin you don't even have to go
all the way through but you could hit a
layer of pumpkin that is almost
uncarvable it will be very very fibrous
and very loose and as soon as you try to
pull the tool across it it'll just fray
and break apart
that gives you an idea of what you're
trying to do when you make a background
adds a little bit more to our guy here
including a nice little tattoo because
he's he's a monster but he loves his mom
and as you can see with a
three-dimensional background it allows
you to appreciate the pumpkin from more
than one angle with a classic pumpkin
you are pretty much restricted to
viewing it from one point of view next
we're going to increase the complexity
by taking pieces of the pumpkin and
adding it to the outside of the pumpkin
level nine adding additional pieces
it can be very
tricky to do this instead of just a
foreshortened hand you actually have a
hand coming out from the pumpkin first
thing i'm gonna do is cut off some
pieces of pumpkin from the back all that
back that you're not using that's raw
materials you can use super glue which
works surprisingly well especially for
small pieces or for larger pieces you're
going to want to use dowel rods to give
the extra piece a bit of support and
sink it in it becomes very breakable so
it's not only
something to sink into the pumpkin to
keep it in place a dowel rod is also
there to reinforce the piece that you're
attaching at this point i've got the two
small horns shaped it's a lot easier to
shave something down when it's in one
whole piece i've waited to separate them
until the end pumpkin is always going to
be extremely slippery and using sharp
tools often ones like a rasp that you're
often drawing towards you the tinier the
piece the more of a pain it's going to
be to work with
and now i've got to carve into where i'm
going to rest the horns this is for a
couple of reasons one
because you want to sink the pumpkin in
there so it really looks like it is part
of the piece and two if you have a
little part where it rests in it it
secures better and these things don't
have to be absolutely perfect remember
he is a monster
after the gluing process slice up the
horns against the head again really make
sure that it fits well
and now you've got a monster with horns
it's something that it's not truly a
huge change but it definitely adds
something just a little bit more i
wonder what else we could put on there
level 10 3d carving with lights
in this pumpkin i'm going to be adding
some light to the eyes it's going to be
different than adding light to the
pumpkins we did in earlier levels
because we no longer have the rind to
block that light from coming out
remember you shaved off the opaque part
of it so the whole pumpkin may light up
the area that i want lit on this is his
eye that seems like a really cool effect
to do that i need to get to the back of
the eye easiest way to do that is that
hole that i just cut
for the horns i'm just gonna use the saw
widen it out a little bit and you can
see now i can reach my hand in there
you're gonna get some gunk all over your
arm but you know that happens it's
pumpkin carving now what i'm going to do
here is reach into the loop tool and
shave the back of the eye down just a
little bit i do want to make a nice flat
spot where i can attach that light if i
push on the pumpkin i can get a little
bit of an idea of where i'm at to make
this light more precise i need to narrow
down its beam a little bit so for that
i'm going to be using aluminum foil to
block a good part of it just cut the
tiniest hole in it so you can really
make that light go exactly where you
want it to and you can see how much it's
refocused that beam
put the light in this little wire
bracket that i've made and it'll just
stick in place
okay that works out pretty well for
classic jack-o-lanterns and some of the
previous pumpkins we've carved light is
necessary it's the thing that makes that
jack-o-lantern work for this light is
more of an accent piece a fun thing to
add on top of everything else because
what doesn't look cooler with glowing
eyes
level 11 using multiple pumpkins this
level increases in complexity just by
using more materials you typically have
a core pumpkin and then kind of a
sacrificial pumpkin that is there for
spare parts so you can cut pieces off
and add it and that's what we're going
to be doing here first i'm going to draw
out exactly what i want on the side of
that pumpkin it's an example of how each
level builds on the skills that you
learned in the previous levels and now
just cut it out with my saw
right now i'm using the rasp to just
round off those edges i don't literally
want to take anything off the back all
i'm doing is taking that sharp corner
off because it'll look just a little bit
better without that it doesn't have to
be absolutely perfect this guy is a
monster but he's kind of a cartoon
looking monster so it's more fun to keep
them slightly silly looking
the next step is to make sure that these
fits exactly how i want them on the core
pumpkin using big pieces that's when you
start to get into the realm of armature
and having things really lock into place
and these are just barbecue skewers you
can find pretty much anywhere you go to
the grocery store and you can find these
things the skewers are going to go from
the wing and stick all the way into the
base of the pumpkin since this wing is a
bit more out than the other wing is it's
a bit more resistant to staying put i
went ahead and attached them so they
weren't even because he's positioned so
one shoulder is raised and the other one
is coming down typically
creatures like us we don't stand
perfectly rigid and exactly the same on
either side and apparently neither do
monsters now i'm not going to add any
more pieces of pumpkin to this but i'm
going to do one last thing to add one
more level of complexity and just pop up
the details just a tiny bit more level
12 painting the pumpkin
we've done a great deal of sculpture and
work on this thing paint is a great way
to accent all that hard work to really
make it stand out personally i like to
only add a little bit of shadow to get
some accent in there because i like
people to really see that no that's
that's pumpkin even though with the
details carved into it you get these
nice dark spots pumpkin is light and it
is translucent so it doesn't necessarily
give you these nice defined shadows
quite as defined as you might want them
to be i personally prefer using an
airbrush i know that's a tool that a lot
of people don't have it's kind of a
specialty device but you can use just
acrylic paint and a little brush and get
some color in it is a very wet surface
don't be surprised if you come back an
hour later and you put your hand on it
and the paint just comes off on your
hands because it's not really going to
dry on this don't worry about the noise
that's just the airbrush compressor
pumping itself back up that's actually
pretty quiet for an airbrush compressor
and now this is our finished pumpkin
handsome as he is our completed pumpkin
really builds on everything that we've
learned so far in the previous levels
once you've learned how to sculpt in
three dimensions you really have to nail
that realism at every angle we've added
additional pieces to the outside of the
pumpkin we've used lights to create
accents we've incorporated multiple
pumpkins to build this piece up and
finally we've actually used some paint
to really punch us some detail and add
shadow level 13 pushing the limits
at this point what we're doing is
basically just completely showing off
you're taking the pumpkin and using it
not as a pumpkin really anymore just as
raw materials you're often taking it and
turning it into something that no longer
resembles pumpkin at all you're using
what you learned in terms of sculpture
in terms of thickness of the pumpkin and
how sturdy it is and attaching it
together the design that i've got for
this level is the upper torso of a
pumpkin zombie now i've got this steel
armature that i've built covered in wire
and mesh and i'm going to be taking
pieces of pumpkin and layering it on to
that armature you can't build an
armature out of just like pvc pipe and a
dowel rod if you're going to be stacking
a lot of pumpkin on it you need steel
and you need heavy amounts of wood to
make sure it can hold the other problem
is those heavy pieces of pumpkin they
break they slide off pumpkin is slippery
it does all sorts of stuff so you have
to figure out a way to anchor it to
that frame and i've also got servos
mounted inside of the head so we'll be
putting pumpkin on top of that and
hopefully it'll move once it's all done
it's trying to do everything that none
of these materials want to do
level 13 breaking every rule i based it
off of zombie movies that i've seen
mongolian armor and just
way too much time spent playing video
games and watching horror flicks and
happily it all actually works
these represent my levels of pumpkin
carving other carvers will certainly
have their own interpretation of what
that means but this is what complexity
means to me the future of pumpkin
carving is taking traditional
jack-o-lanterns like this developing new
techniques and building and trying new
things very much like we've done here
today and it'll just keep progressing
like that into the future
thank you wired